okay uh trendy but not functional could
apply to jameis winston at least as it
relates to the fact that he's become
kind of a cult hero in nfl figures i
mean people love the guy because they
love watching him play not because he's
patrick holmes or lamar jackson but
because
it increases the level of excitement for
any given play because as soon as he
lets go of the football you never know
where it's going to go and you know
that's one of the things i love the most
about watching a football game on tv and
not in person because of the limitations
of the image that gets projected when
the quarterback lets go of the ball down
the field you know more than just five
or ten yards like the pick six that iced
the game on sunday for the bucks you
never know what's going to happen the
ball exits the screen is there a guy
open is he covered is it gonna get
picked off is it gonna get caught with
jameis winston it really is a roll of
the dice and that's one of the reasons
why he's so exciting chris no doubt it's
can't miss football i mean it's
constantly aggressive there's a lot of
great plays and then you know
out of you know one every 10 plays you
go
what the hell was that i can't believe
that that's so stupid and in the era of
like fantasy football
i mean his point out footage on a weekly
basis is is probably great i heard
somebody say yesterday like did you say
outputted did you say point output yes i
did without footage yes i did say that
just making sure but i heard somebody
say yesterday my you know the host that
does uh chris sims unbutton with me
ahmed fareed he was saying that like
people say to him they start jameis
winston as their quarterback in fantasy
and then they start the defense he's
playing as well and they come out on top
i thought that was kind of cool that's a
new trend
so here's where things stand jameis
winston's five-year contract with the
buccaneers remember he was the first
overall pick in 2015. the contract is
expired he'll he's due to become a free
agent in march i explained sunday night
on football night in america that
there's been no discussions no
negotiations no effort to try to extend
that contract it's all going to be
deferred after the season the first
question for the bucks do they want
jameis winston and also very important
to this analysis
do other teams
want jameis winston and i think part of
the game that's being played we'll talk
more about this after we share with you
the clip from bruce aaron's coach of the
buccaneers from yesterday but i think
part of the game is scaring other teams
away from jameis winston here is bruce
arians who provided yet again a less
than glowing assessment of his
quarterback's performances from monday
this team is it good enough to win with
another quarterback
with another quarterback oh yeah
we can win with this one we can win we
can definitely win with another one too
because we're going to have a defense
now
it reads you know
when he talks about it talks it it reads
different than it talks
but but you're right you're right when i
saw the quote yesterday i thought holy
crap when you see it his point is our
defense is going to be better but he
said if we can win with this one we can
win with another one and that is the the
bigger point here the idea that
you know
they're trying to be coy they're trying
to
get jameis winston if they decide to
keep him and i think they will decide to
keep him under the best possible
financial terms that they can they don't
want teams lined up out the door trying
to pursue jameis winston then you got to
use the franchise tag or the transition
tag and spend more money than you'd like
to spend right they want to keep them
around for the lowest possible financial
investment and with the greatest amount
of flexibility that if that 33 and 30
touchdowns the interceptions from this
year becomes 25 and 40 next year you
want to be able to get rid of the guy
but but you know here's the thing
chris
he had 5109 passing yards yeah last year
yeah that's eighth all time and when you
look at the list and i did this on radio
earlier down the list of the all-time
great single season passing yardage
performances there isn't a single guy
that his team was ambivalent about him
they're all star quarterbacks there's no
doubt that he's the guy and even if it's
a guy who oh you know maybe we you know
he's not a great quarterback in
hindsight that was a great year for the
guy like eli manning in 2011 rich gannon
in 2002 when he was the league mvp right
the all-time great single season passing
yardage performances were all authored
by guys who were no brainer franchise
quarterbacks and it's amazing i mean
it's even a question he threw 5 100
yards of course you want him back well
no not of course you want him back
because he lost you games this year too
i mean just he did there's no other way
to put it you know there was moments
where he did that so
there is a lot to build on positively
but there's some negative there that
makes you scared to build at all and i
guess the big thing is is like here's
the first question
just looking at it right now like who
want who's gonna want jameis winston
right now like what team like can you
really
pin that to to go oh
that makes sense i just think there's
some gamesmanship here going on by the
bucks by the comments we saw bruce aaron
they're trying to scare people away
they don't want they don't want somebody
to sit down and say hmm
jameis winston had 5 100 passing yards
maybe we should pursue him next year i
think it's more about they're just
trying to drive his price down and i
think that's very much a real thing in
the nfl you know i kind of told this
story on my podcast yesterday in 2015 i
remember the broncos were secretly going
around telling people that demarcus ware
was better than von miller and you know
i was like oh von miller contract year
very interesting you're saying that
because he's not better than von miller
okay that's crazy to say that but this
is the crap teams do a little bit to
drive that price down and i think that's
kind of what they're doing
i don't know if there's going to be a
team out there one i guess i would say
this is there a team out there that one
is going to want jameis winston and all
the mistakes he makes at times right and
then two jameis winston comes with some
off the field stuff as well you know
so there's there's a knowing of the
person in jameis winston in florida
being from florida state and you know
being there in tampa so uh you know i
think he's created a little niche for
himself in tampa as well but i just go
you know it's hard to sit here and look
at nfl teams right now and go
who other than tampa bay is really going
to sign up for jameis winston right now
i think that's where it gets interesting
to his credit to his credit and and he
has had some off the field issues that
that that impair his image in league
circles right past couple of years have
been without incidents yeah and he's
grown from
from those experiences but but it's
still you can't make them go away right
um i you know
i think it will be very telling because
this year there are plenty of veteran
free agent quarterbacks available
and uh we'll start to hear if there are
teams interested i don't think you can
keep your cards pressed all that close
to the vest because the agent will try
to generate interest and the moment the
agent catches wind of another team
interested we're going to hear about it
right and and because that hopefully
leads to another team being interested
before you know it the you know the
buccaneers are going to have to use the
franchise tag or there's going to be a
land rush for jameis winston and i'm
just going to throw out a couple of
teams what do you think your your guy
john gruden would do with james winston
would you rather have jameis winston or
derek carr well
i think for the way john gruden wants to
play i think there's a higher ceiling
with jameis winston i'll say that much
okay yes but
i don't know you know john gruden he's
very into completion percentage and
taking care of the football that way i
think he would pull his hair out with
jameis winston i just don't think that
would work i can't see that happening
he's a little would he think he can fix
him
all these coaches think they can fix a
guy no john's not that kind of guy to
develop and fix we know that i mean
that's he's famous for that right i mean
that's just my my gut there i mean he's
famous for wanting the guy that he's
seen already been there done that oh
i'll put him in my offense i don't want
to have to like groom him and teach him
quarterback mechanics and things like
that that's not what gruden does gruden
wants to run his offense put in a lot of
plays a lot of checks and he wants a guy
that can run the offense and play at a
high level i don't think he's into you
know grooming young you know not young
guys but guys in general
yeah i mean i've seen his work with a
third round draft picks right i
understand exactly yeah it drove him
crazy it drove him crazy and then it
drove him crazy that i had talent and
people were like you should start sims
and he's like oh i mean how the hell are
you telling me who to start i mean i
just know more than you so yeah i get it
i get
it hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports